[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et la grandiloquence je surprends
magnétique non là on en a que la commune
ait un petit billy crawford c'est fini
je me suis donc c'est non pour à venir
microphone n'ont jamais partie avec les
robots c'est bien mettre la familia il
est très connu un solide l'animateur
préféré des piles de cartons philippines
genre et non mais je vous dis là bas ces
genres cyril féraud
moi j'adore s'irriter route voilà c'est
ma référence fort il marche forcée et
pas aux cavalcades sur les croise ou
comment vous allez tout le monde
gilles on a un peu concentré on commence
par gribouillé les toits on et focus a
bossé bienvenue dans le 20h 45 de
l'humour avec des gants de velours c'est
quoi ces les images les plus marquantes
de ces dernières 24 heures la maj comme
l'appellent les notables c'est un vrai
sujet de sa mise
[Musique]
messieurs le cerveau et on a appris que
michel même quand il avec les kids
united
ils surveillent pas non plus son langage
et leur parle comme à eddy mitchell il
ya certaines chansons que je
redécouvrais gsm-r 10 ans fait mieux que
moi là je vous comprends
j'en chie c'est un travail de titan qui
bien sûr en déplacement en algérie
regarder cette image on a appris que guy
roux a passé un bon moment il s'est
vraiment éclaté guéroult alors gignac
ont joué quand j'ai chez lui ouah jam le
théâtre le loto bien aux olives et non
au niveau c'est très élevé elle est si
bonne on a appris que celui des enfants
ils sont hyper toth a vu à la viande le
17 octobre
on va souhaiter un très bon anniversaire
eminem a
[Musique]
s'il a 44 ans il est journaliste il en
entend acculé matin next voici les
images de maxime dénis qui arrivent le
matin la rédac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le maxi la dj clyde et pas y'a quoi
à quoi le divin c'est parce qu'il aime
jouer ouais je sais vous allez jouer
ouais on va faire un rébus soja
devançant brute d'amd très bon répond
par des biens pour parler d'un animateur
à vous de deviner lequel
pour piero points pour pierrot j'adore
je relance le rébus aujourd'hui marie
france elle était pas mal stressé
stressé mais franche c'est comme ça
qu'on l'ait marie-france jarry chèvre ça
va marie france et j'en passe vous êtes
tout stressé près c'est vrai qu'est ce
qui pourrait vous déstresser guise qui
avait tout le monde a vu un petit coup
pour se détendre à la plupart ceux vus
comme on lui fait la bise en partant tu
as l'impression de voir jean me à 5
heures du mat en boîte
dans la drôme a dit donc or il attrape
paris france 2 et 3 de 8,1 et avant de
partir le parler de maintien de paris
nice france pendant voulez passer un
coucou pense savoir qui l'accompagnent
marie-france vrai avec les figures à la
gym gymnastique
on va faire un gros bisou un gros neveu
qui est ici qu on ne veut trop sympa de
la compagne et à thiais la télé alors à
toi si recentre son petit neveu on
s'demande
et bah ça on va faire un gros bisou un
gros neveu qui est ici pour jean-marc
bienvenus
[Musique]
ça ne paye pas c'est vrai j'ai jacadi
personne ne bouge pendant prochain
lancement accord regardez une vidéo qui
fait le buzz le ramdam comme disent pas
les jeunes c'est un gars qui a mis une
pierre je pas si vous l'avez vu cette
image
une pierre dans sa machine à laver en
chef a vu je vous promets on n'a pas
toujours des bonnes idées c'est que
pierre qui roule n'amasse pas mousse
c'est pas vrai voici ce que je viens
d'entendre ça
attendez ça me rappelle quelque chose
parvenu dans enquête exclusive
éric dugas dans le meilleur pâtissier on
a trouvé la candidate qui verra pas la
finale à mon avis pour elle parlait bref
c'est une étape du tour de france
c'était ce que c'est bon pour lui placer
je vais inventer quelque chose la tarte
un temps ça a été une erreur dans les
anciens candidats qui a voulu tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé légèrement à paris je
là on connaissait plus trop ces derniers
temps même si on a déjà parlé
et pendant ce temps là dans des chiffres
et des lettres ils ont reçu la candidate
la plus fraîche de toute l'histoire du
jeu
c'est cette demoiselle bertrand renard
est sous le charme en finit pas bravo
dommage dommage ça veut dire 712 oui
j'ai jamais pu peser sur du calcul
mental je ne suis pas assez bonnes
[Applaudissements]
le gars ici des gens tout d'abord on
n'avait jamais démenti ces allégations
tirs
je voulais vous faire une petite
surprise je vous ferai une surprise mais
je tiens plus je vous ai préparé un top
3 non mais j'ai passé mon devoir
3 qu'est ce qu'on dit c'est qu'annie
préférant augmente mais merci je crois
aussi on va lire merci les plus beaux
buts de la semaine ça vous dit ça vous
dit oui le moose en partant parti numéro
3 à regarder c'est bruno le pote de
norbert dans la meilleure boulangerie
suresnes d'un divorce c'est le je ne
sais plus quoi à la française donc qui
sait comment ça ça fait ça la foudre est
la branlette la bombe française numéro
deux dans 9h50 une chroniqueuse a
tellement accroché la solitude teuton
temps la clim derrière et donc j'aurai
dissimulant vous n'arrêtez pas tous mais
tous dans un coin et puis un art qui m'a
accueilli à lever le toit il m'a dit
madame c'est pas possible on evans et
iacocca quoi dans la salle de classe
c'était une blague là c'est lolo mèche
coach me paraît le zidane du
le pdg de la foire h compagnie emploie
pas faire mieux j'avais cinq lettres
avec 6 j et si ça décrit crise et un nom
un grigri du grillon ah oui d'accord
c'est pas cricri d'amour à me laisser
[Applaudissements]
elle tombe
un dakar
macquet aucune machine je gardais les jt
aussi j'allais bfm ça aurait fait ils
m'ont surpris je vous jure passe
maintenant il faut les jeux perdus les
gars sur bfm n'assume pas content on
pense quoi votre frère sans faire exprès
[Rires]
proclamé son indépendance il ya un
député qui a pris la parole à
l'assemblée un député il sera encouragé
par ses potes tu as l'impression qu'il
doit réciter une poésie au tableau c'est
non parole est à monsieur sébastien
leclerc monsieur le président chers
collègues et un petit je saurai vous
retrouvez le manque du parlement chinois
cap eu le temps de récupérer son costume
au pressing c'est pas lui c'est pas lui
la pollution à l'officine plus puissants
du pays qu'on plaçait s'est passé je
costaud clé s'assurer look
on prend des nouvelles de notre ancien
ministre michel sapin on est contents
alors que ces nouvelles il a décidé de
se lancer dans la pêche et la main
adopter le look du commandant cousteau
la troisième année historique depuis les
gares n'y a plus autant qu'à toujours le
temps tu fais tout ce que tu veux et le
roi du monde
or on harcèle eux c'est la télé qui se
répondent j'adore quand on zappe sais
plus ce que je sais c'est que quand tu
réponds c'était attention mais c'était
un truc piquant la thrombose et l'actuel
bien compris quand vous le savez
aujourd'hui quand on se fait flasher en
voiture sur l'autoroute c'est quatre
points de retrait 120 euros d'amendé un
après mais carole rousseau salle est
partout il ya plus un docu où l est pas
sur ces 8 milliards soit aussi avait des
100 jours avec la gendarmerie attend on
a trouvé un policier qui on a suivi hier
ça va vous on a compris pour que vous
appelez pas 100 jours un pékin delhi
circle sera gardé une famille suédoise
se présente on réalise qu'on fasse un
tueur
l'ophone hockey news l' ue qui ont à
boisson à 10 des youyous là
série aux états unis kim a cartonné
starsky and hutch lui ces stars s'y est
lui out on a trouvé au poil intérêts
pour s'adonner un gendarme qui vous
contrôler pour un excès de vitesse
ils étaient un million deux cent mille
we you est sorti de là vous avez permis
21e ils ont décidé de suivre la vie dans
une caserne de pompiers une vie sous
pression bien sûr le répit est de courte
durée
les premiers appels au secours de nuit
sont chez nous
[Musique]
l'action trop cool alors des scènes de
foule sur une taylor profite d'un moment
de calme pour changer le fond d'écran de
l'ordinateur de la salle des rapports
[Musique]
saluer mais c'est ça aussi ça a très
bien marché la gendarmerie aussi avec
emilie besse conte à qui je fais de gros
gros bisous et voilà et je lui remets
recycler remercie pour le sms comme
envoyer tout à l'heure c'est un amour
non c'est une amie mais je sais ma vie
de la chaîne et on espère qu'elle fera
encore plus de choses dans la chaîne
vous savez que il ya plus qu'un
fabricant de sabots en france n'ont pas
prêté genre ailleurs pernod ricard
ouais c'est christophe dans le
[Rires]
mystérieux dont la femme c'est jp c'est
un secret pour personne jean-pierre
pernaut il ya dans la campagne
voilà mais il est malgré tout obligés de
clôturer son jt avec un mot sur la
bourse mais jusqu'au bout on sent que
c'est pas son truc aujourd'hui était à
deux doigts de dire ce qu'ils pensent
vraiment de la bourse
quand volder je vous l'avais dit de nous
on continue on ira en camargue la bourse
de paris s'est pas passé loin j'obtiens
pernaut qui aujourd'hui encore nous a
donné les infos de ouf ipea urgentes qui
pouvait pas attendre
noël c'est pas tout de suite c'est dans
9 semaines merci j'opère jeremstar lui
était l'invité des grandes gueules sur
rmc on a senti qu olivier marchal a eu
très très peur de la dinde et la page
j'ai adoré mon mariage c'était vrai que
la mairie ça a beaucoup choqué mais ce
n'est pas non plus une orgie fin c'était
pas dire ici que j'ai même failli
dépasser le mobilier de collection en
talons et carnet rose jean-mi à une
petite aventure il ya quelques années
avec georges brassens
on sait pas mais leur fils était chez
nagui aujourd'hui le forage à la dèche
analyse à sion à la vente
[Applaudissements]
je vous fais c'est le même bien oui
c'est ou tchadors débiteur il ya un gros
buzz en vraiment ça a été plus de 11
personnes à me réclamer blog notre
séquence la télé se répondent is back
on regarde la télé comme vous et c'est
parfois quand on zappe on tombe sur des
moments les chaînes sont gérés ça donne
des phrases qui peuvent avoir un autre
son frère c'est génial ici c'est toi qui
est génialissime toinon soit le plus
rien a fini les toiles on regarde et on
va parler d'un sujet comme on dit chez
nous concernant le transit intestinal
pourquoi le style on nous tente de
traces sans creuser ses concerts mais
quand il s'agit de déposer sa crotte lui
on est au bord des larmes a c'est toute
l'année ou ici en là je suis dans mon
slip on vous surnomme j'adore son petit
surnom ou surnomme la reine de paix peut
alors il y en a de toutes sortes
laurent wauquiez favori pour la
présidence du parti qui dans ce but
n'hésite pas à la bourre et le choc sur
un toit brûlant de marine le pen
non nous on est tous les deux très
tactile un j'aime beaucoup de toucher
des boules noires
[Applaudissements]
alors très vite on se quitte là dessus
je souhaite un bon week-end avec gmail
en même temps avec le traitement des
demandes d'augmentation de cyril hanouna
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la suivante à l'autoradio